A new trailer’s out for Westworld Season
2 and it hints at some of the themes that
we’ll see in series ahead.
If you haven’t seen our Season 1 video,
you might wanna watch that first.
In this trailer, Dolores talks about burning
down the human world and building a “new
world” where the hosts – the robots – can
be free . So Dolores seems to be waging war
against the humans remaining in Westworld
– we see her gunning down fleeing people,
like something outta Planet of the Apes.
Her victims run away – which makes the Kanye
soundtrack all the more appropriate.
Dolores isn’t alone in her war.
She’s got her sidekick Teddy, who mostly
just follows her round and looks upset, but
she also has these mysterious masked men.
We’re actually told who these guys are back
in Season 1.
Charlotte mentions that as part of his final
narrative, Ford created “a horde of masked
men” who support Wyatt . And Wyatt, remember,
is like the big bad guy role from years ago
that’s now been embraced by Dolores.
So presumably, these masked men help Dolores
in her fight for freedom against the humans.
But that raises the question – if this whole
story of Wyatt and the masked men was planned
out by Ford – is Dolores really free, or
is she still under Ford’s control, even
after his death?
Maeve also attacks humans.
She uses robot bulls to kill security guys
in the Mesa Hub, and there’s also a fight
in the Control Room where Maeve meets Sizemore
last trailer.
The bull thing calls back to something Dolores
said last season – when you herd cattle,
there’s a “Judas steer” that all the
others cows follow.
Maybe Maeve is the Judas steer leading the
other hosts to consciousness and freedom.
But thing is, while the cattle follow the
Judas steer, the Judas steer is controlled
by the human cattle rancher – just as Ford
seems to be controlling Maeve and Dolores.
So again, Ford’s ghost looms over the story
still.
Another explanation for the bulls is that
last season, Maeve is upgraded with the ability
to control other hosts – she uses this on
a sheriff, and even on Bernard.
This power might be how Maeve controls these
bulls, which is super cool – for her to
control an animal army, like she was Ant Man
or Squirrel Girl or some homicidal version
of Snow White.
But if Maeve represents freedom, isn’t it
wrong for her to control other hosts like
this, to take away their freedom?
Again it’s kinda like how Ford gives hosts
freedom by manipulating them.
Anyway.
Maeve’s goal, at the end of Season 1, is
to find her host daughter somewhere in a park.
What will happen when Maeve finds her?
What kind of relationship can you have with
a daughter who’s a robot, whose memories
and behaviours are programmed?
How do you love a machine?
There are lots of cool questions to explore
around relationships among robots and humans.
While Maeve and Dolores cause chaos and violence,
some surviving human staff are with Bernard.
It’ll be cool to see how these humans react
if they find out their boss Bernard is a host.
The staff see bodies on the shore of Westworld
– which might be what’s left after Dolores’
massacre last season.
We also see Bernard with a big faceless host
who attacks someone.
Is this like an experimental robot, maybe
a military thing?
We keep hearing last season that the Delos
company has some special secret business interest
that goes deeper than tourism . Maybe this
creepy robot is related.
We also see the host Peter Abernathy captured
in the Mesa Hub, which is weird – cause
last we saw Peter, he was sent out of Westworld
by Charlotte and Sizemore, who were using
Peter’s brain to smuggle data . If Pete
left the park, why’s he back here?
Maybe this shot happens in the past.
Because there’s also this shot of Logan,
young Logan, as he looked thirty years ago
with William.
It looks like Season 2 continues to tell this
story in multiple timeframes at once – there’s
the present, with Maeve and Dolores’ uprising,
and the past with William and Logan in early
Westworld thirty years ago.
Maybe we’ll find out more about how Delos
bought Westworld, and how William took control
over Logan.
This particular shot looks like Logan’s
in the real world, outside of Westworld, cause
there’re city skyscapes behind him.
This might be New York, like in the photo
of Logan’s sister Juliet.
But the people around Logan in this shot appear
to be hosts, cause they’re all frozen – so
this is not only the first time we’ve seen
the real world outside Westworld, but we’re
seeing hosts in the real world.
What kind of role do robots play in this future
society?
What kinda technology, and culture might we
see?
This shot also might be in the past – it
looks like Arnold with an early Dolores, so
maybe we’ll see more of their backstory.
Dolores wears a dress and hair similar to
Angela in Season 1 Episode 2.
Maybe Dolores was originally gonna be a greeter
host like Angela.
Also remember that Peter is Dolores’ host
father, so maybe we’ll see more of their
relationship.
We’ll also see more of young William, and
his present self, the Man in Black.
Last season, William wanted real danger and
violence in Westworld, and now with Dolores’
war he’s got his wish.
His role last season was to show how dark
and empty humans can be.
Maybe next season will be an opportunity for
William to change – to believe in something
more than just fighting and winning.
We see hosts from Ghost Nation, a mysterious
tribe of native Americans in the Westworld
park.
They captured Stubbs last season, and might
have him still.
But their role in the story could go deeper
– we saw last season that these guys know
things about the maze , and about shades . They
also scalp people, which is interesting cause
it was in a scalp that we first saw the symbol
of the Maze.
So it’s not clear what side Ghost Nation
will take in Dolores and Maeve’s conflicts,
but it’ll be cool to learn more about what
they know.
We also see this dog or “wolf” walking
around.
It looks like the same one that appears in
the Season 1 finale and in Season 1 Episode
2.
Why does this wolf keep turning up at massacres?
Is it wandering across from the Game of Thrones
set?
You can actually see a wolf’s head in this
shot of Arnold and early Dolores – so maybe
this wolf is a host that’s been wandering
round for the last thirty years?
It’s very odd.
So there are lots of little miscellaneous
mysteries in this show, and we might not get
good answers to all of them.
But there is grand broader story.
The central image of this trailer is the clash
of these robot bulls against human soldiers,
which perfectly captures the conflict explored
in this series.
It’s about freedom versus control, and the
real versus the artificial – and it’s
increasingly hard to tell which is which.
The robots are machines but they seem wild
and free, like Dolores and Maeve.
These soldiers are the real humans but they
seem cold, faceless and dehumanised – like
the Man in Black.
Westworld Season 1 is described as a “prequel”
or a “prologue” to the greater story – it
introduces the characters, world and themes.
But Season 2 is where the clash happens.
Man and machine, Westworld and East world,
present and past – all come together at
last.
Season 2 begins on April 22.
If you want more Westworld videos from Alt
Shift X, make sure to like and subscribe and
comment what you’d like to see next.
We do have a Season 1 video if you haven’t
already seen that, explaining the intricacies
of the timeline, and Ford’s plan and all
that.
We also got our Game of Thrones videos, with
analyses of theories, characters and more.
Thank you to the Patrons who make Alt Shift
X possible, including Ryan Yoosefi, Juan Camilo
Rodriguez, Nicole Tovar, Kristin, Graham King,
Fred The Easter Bunny, and Shapedlikebacon.
Cheers.